see those glowing specks of light yeah
nerves are so shot okay fragments of
spirit scattered through the halls of
this little man okay gather them all and
the first puzzle piece will be ready yes
ma'am
one more thing yeah you're not alone
there's a monster in here kill it
do something I plucked from your worst
nightmare and it's looking okay okay Oh
Oh what is that hello everybody my name
is Mark barn welcome to dark deception I
think is the name of the game and
apparently this is a lot like pac-man
which is weird cuz I just played an
impossible game of pac-man earlier
there's something in here I can hear it
I can hear you that's us oh my god haha
it's a monkey it's a murder monkey the
murder monkeys after me oh my god
there's a lot of shards whoa I give you
an early start learning battle ax
that'll wake you up better than coffee
okay so I got my little monkey friend
coming at me houki akka don't kill me
please don't murder me in the face
I'd be must appreciate if you didn't
where is he
here him I got a little mini map I
barely had time to register what was
going on before I was thrust some thusly
into the mine he found me wait a minute
hang on ah okay he's a little bit closer
than I thought let's do
monkey see monkey kill geez oh oh oh
it's like it is like pack clothes have
my blood on the wall probably not I did
good
thank you lady who is apparently what
what'd you say what'd you say did you
say dumb mommy say something by my mama
what who oh hi you're a bit of a swishy
swashy with those sword awardees I need
to go this way I'm trying to watch my
mini-map also listening to where they
are but it's hard to listen when I'm
yelling in my own ear it's a monkey
heard of that okay
good guy yeah bat get away from a monkey
you monkey goose it's really cool the
way they round the corners that's really
elegant that's really cool and really
disturbing and so cool and so creepy and
so cute not cute okay never mind going
this way didja yeah I don't know what I
expect
okay that's bad hi sorry you startled me
I apologize for anyone anyway back to
you now laughs thank god damn it oh hi
hello friend how you doing over there I
know you back up you son of a [ __ ] want
to play hello I play today oh oh you
creepy fudge I know he's behind me lady
thank you very much I'm very well aware
of where he is
hi okie-dokie
this good is good I like this very good
is my favourite thing actually lecture
Wow
he's right back what are you your monkey
oh god damn it
I shouldn't be messing with the monkeys
but they're just so fun to mess with
monkey monkey see monkey Lu keep going I
am going I'm nearly there they're nearly
up my butt they are trying to stop me in
my patootie
oh hello I don't know what I was trying
to do there I really don't know no buck
burglar get that blue ribbon a blue
baboon balloon where are you white boy
boy boy wake up now now count come I'm
going around the outer perimeter first
because that's a more egregious method
of which way I can do this
apparently something right dad oh hi
wait a minute I need to go there not
today not yet
big guy I'm gonna do it
that old lady ain't got nothing on me
okay where am I good okay let's go this
way
blend it out I hear him what the hell
Chris II to interact what does that even
mean what why why can I do that let me
out there murder monkeys after me I need
to actually get shut up you're lying not
right behind me hi baby
ah son of a [ __ ] oh that's a painting
of the monkeys look at them they're so
adorable hey that looks just like you
I'm gonna run away now okay not going
that way hi um I needed to go there so
if you could not be a son of a [ __ ]
that be today
okay okay no no no no no no
what's with this monkey portal why is
there a monkey portal I am running you
douche man come on Big Boy
bye big boy that's where you are that's
right that's right get it right get it
tight oh I'm about to get it or no oh
what's that oh what's that over there oh
why isn't it over was it done over ah
why is it over ah lucky monkeys murder
monkeys burnham Oh does it
Oh Liz if that's all anything Oh Jack
I'm a bunch of good did blue what you do
know of the door Oh couldn't get it ha
ha ha I was really fun that was
surprisingly really fun I'm gonna be
perfectly honest is there any more to
that oh man oh I thought that was gonna
be more I'm gonna mess with the murder
monkeys just a little bit more Wow
monkey see monkey don't kill me please
Oh monkey hello hello Oh huge a big boy
yeah you double you're a little too
close to me you're a big boy hm he's
really got good anima nations I gotta
admit
that's an elegant monkey ah do close
very close
stranger danger Wow monkey pie
hey I really do wonder if one of these
stores does open hello friend
oh hello Wow hello friend three friends
not too many friends I don't need that
many friends come here come on back
Daniel is behind me hello hi okay bye
what's he doing what's he doing there
what you doing there
what you doing there hi y'all
hello what's going on little buddy does
a fear more monkey my game
man gay Boinga Boinga hi
booga-booga-booga
got them all I'm the winner
still oh no that big ol aw okay there we
go I beat it twice now that wasn't bad
that was actually really fun I'm
actually quite surprised that was an
innovative mechanic I guess if you can
call pac-man innovative but either way
that was a lot of fun you can check the
description down below let me know what
you think of this and I think this is
just a demo so a full version may be
coming out in the future either way this
was really cool so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
oh that's disturbing